a brief moment of joy for these children
outside the dormitory campus in Ankara
but inside there is an anxious weight by
their dots
they're sad terrified and still shocked
After experiencing lost Monday's
powerful earthquakes that hit turkey's
10 southern cities
Canaan and his family are among the
hundreds of thousands who left their
City behind
he says he arrived here five days ago
after burying family members
we woke up to huge shaking and noise it
was flashing everywhere we had no
electricity but we were able to see each
other as if it was daytime my wife was
in shock she hugged me tight I was
trying to gather the kids at the same
time it was like a nightmare in our own
home we were panicking it shook for a
long time we prayed a lot
his wife as she was just four weeks far
from giving birth
when I saw the runes I started crying
and calling my mom and brother I
couldn't get any sound from them I
couldn't do anything I was distraught
they took me away from there because I'm
pregnant
just in the stormy in the Turkish
Capital there are nearly 2 500 citizens
who have been displaced from their homes
without any clothes or shoes still there
thankful they have a roof over their
hats hot water and a warm place to sleep
but it is still not home
unfortunately we left all our memories
youth childhood future and hopes
everything behind and came here and Taki
is totally destroyed but we will return
to our city we will revive this city of
civilizations
even though most of these people lost
their everything they haven't lost their
hope to see another day at least for
their children to rebuild one day
they're not sure when that day will come
but they're aware they have a long way
to go
solo Al Jazeera Ankara